[Applause]
Rishi sunak in salesman mode
at a drinks Factory near Belfast trying
to persuade the audience here and beyond
that his brexit deal is the real thing
an extraordinary positive step for
Northern Ireland moving these workers
with a controversial pitch that with his
new rules Northern Ireland is different
from the rest of the UK with Benefits
other nations have lost Northern Ireland
is in the unbelievably special position
unique position in the entire world
European continent in having privileged
access not just to the UK Home Market
but also the European Union single
Market nobody else has that
no one
only you guys only here
and that is the prize in Westminster
most here are taking time to sift
through the detail of this deal but
confirmation of special status for
Northern Ireland is not something that
unionists or brexiteers welcome even
those Northern Ireland politicians who
like what they hear are surprised that
they're hearing it if he's willing to
acknowledge that having preferential
access to the EU single Market is a good
thing economically I think that's that's
a good thing that he's acknowledging
that of course I would say it's slightly
betterly ironic for some of the
businesses in England and Scotland Wales
who are benefiting for 40 or more years
from from single Market access to hacked
here you know a brexit government
lowered the benefits of the single
Market but and for the perspective of
Northern Ireland it is progress
this was a deal months in the making
it's now his own MPS that Rishi sunak
needs to persuade
Behind these windows the whole party
gathered to hear his sales pitch most
happy to go along with what they heard
what I think is the first time in my uh
almost 18-year career as a conservative
Member of Parliament but where there
were no hostile questions
it was very positive resounding
endorsement from MPS of all Persuasions
today including hard brexiteers who
brought down previous Prime Ministers
over their Brussels negotiations that
there are a few grumbles and complaints
in private from Tory MPS but most
conservatives seem to know that the very
narrow chance of success at the next
election relies on this deal being
called a success and big beast it's not
coming out to oppose it
one man's judgment still unclear are you
going to be able to vote for this deal
he won't want to be out in the cold for
long Sam coat Sky News Westminster